Open your eyes...
Open your eyes.
Wake up Link...
Link...
You are our final hope.
The Great Calamity was merciless...
It devastated everything in its path,
a century ago.
However...
The princess survived...
You must save her,
my daughter!
Link...
You are the light,
that must shine upon Hyrule once again.
Now go.
Link...
You are our final hope.
The fate of Hyrule rests with you!
Link...
Link!
My daughter's power will soon be exhausted.
Once that happens,
this world will face it's end,
and nothing will stop him from consuming our land.
You must hurry Link,
I trust that you understand your duty...
protect her,
my daughter.
Considering that I could not save my own Kingdom
Link!
I have no right to ask this of you,
but I am powerless here.
You must save her...
my daughter.
and do whatever it takes to annihilate Ganon.
The Master Sword...
I heard it speak to me.
Your master will come for you.
Until then,
you shall rest safely here.